vous voulez mettre trente deux heures le
35 il voulait augmenter le smic à 1500
euros
mais c'est un peu fou vendée un peu du
rêve ça fait un peu élections des
délégués seraient le jeu en fait c'est
travailler moins pour gagner plus bah
oui
et vous pensez pas qu'on a besoin de
rêver un petit peu là sa tête que vous
êtes en train de voir dans vos
transistors et dans votre téléviseur
petit voyeur que vous êtes vous allez
continuer de la voir régulièrement
voilà trente six ans voulons non ça
c'est une insulte
m pap est déjà aujourd'hui je le voyais
je sais pas ce que je pense qu on vous
compare souvent à à monsieur à monsieur
burns dans les simpson ah oui je le
connais oui quoi il est plutôt drôle
birdie
comment il est là qu'il a battu trouvera
donc jouer ensemble enfin lancer les
gens s'étonnent t'es dur avec moi
je prenais comment bien ça me fait rire
ou pas c'est pas grave tu sais on peut
se moquer
qu'est ce qu'ils faisaient une hostie
cela je comprends rien moi entre
polémique politique et président a
d'unique il ya quand même une sorte de
distance qui nous sommes pas si simple
de franchir
c'est quand même un mégalomane ce avec
le temps est venu d'engager une
résistance
comme chaque famille nous traquons
maintenant les infos qui vont circuler
sur le net cette semaine et ce soir pour
démêler le vrai du faux
d 01
01 m
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la bien diane âge et haddock
trop impatient de voir la suite du film
non mais c'était une petite ballerine
poète
o o
waouh on a ramené un punching ball
là on peut pas les séparer
vous faites de la boxe thaï
[Rires]
avec deux ans même quand c'est plus dur
de retourner une basse
je veux plus entendre un mot de ta
bouche rose
engines alors c'était une blague
parle pas de ma femme ok ok promis
ok il faut toujours se méfier avec les
histoires de héros car comme l'écrivait
gainsbourg dans son roman evgeny sokolov
le masque tombe l'homme reste est le
héros
s'évanouit j'en connais qui a qu'a perdu
en revanche son sang froid pendant au
top la station c'est le monsieur à qui
appartient ce micro c'est tu peux lui
rendre c'est denis voilà autant de nice
et le patron d'emmi projet lâché
check on le et tu le dis si un problème
toi tu me dis tout le temps s'inquiète
on enverra la facture c'est sur ces 8000
takata